let's talk about uh let's talk about
donald trump and vladimir putin we have
the story of the new york post trump
talks about putin mocking merkel and
more at mar-a-lago boy did they bury the
lead on this one the story is about
donald trump threatening to hit the
capitals of russia
and china
this is i mean these are bold statements
so you want to know why
why is it that vladimir putin did not
invade ukraine under trump
there there's there's this top post on
reddit where they're like because you
know russia put bounties on soldiers in
afghanistan and trump didn't even do
anything about the story was fake yeah
and so this would they believe no no let
me show you exactly what it is i will
scroll down and give you this
there are several other stories making
the rounds too this is from the from the
article and they are even more
provocative one has it that trump noting
that putin seized land from georgia when
george w bush was president and seized
the crimean peninsula when barack obama
was president warned putin against a
land grab on his watch if you move
against ukraine while i'm president i
will hit moscow
putin reportedly scoffed no way and
trump said all those beautiful golden
turrets will be blown up he reportedly
said the same thing to xi jinping that
if he made a move against taiwan it
would be met with an attack on beijing
she like putin has said to have been
stunned though it's possible neither man
believed trump was serious
i kind of don't like the idea of bombing
civilian targets immediately as soon as
a regional war happens
but let it be said trump was was called
a madman by his by his enemies and his
supporters and and and i just want to
say
i don't i don't believe trump would bomb
civilians i mean he's the guy who said
we're we're calling off the airstrike on
iran because
too many people would die
but trump is notorious for the big ask
he he exaggerates his position and then
pulls back to a more reasonable spot
that's what he does he says i'll buy
that uh you know i'll you know if i'm
doing the job i want a million dollars
and they say oh million that's crazy
okay how about half a million now he's
getting you to half a million dollars in
this instance he goes to moscow he go or
he goes to uh putin
if you invade ukraine
i will hit moscow and putin's like no
and trump's like yes and putin's like
okay
this guy's this guy's a little off his
you know and they know that he'll be out
in four years they know that the
american democracy is a republicanism
putin was like
let the you know hold like the
braveheart mean meme hold and then biden
comes in he's like we good yeah
well and nobody nobody thinks
i mean again this is also some people
think that diplomacy works with
everybody because they honestly believe
that well if we all just sat around the
room and we talked and we understood one
another like
i can't remember who it was that said
that you know israel and and gaza
understand each other oh they do yeah
they they don't they don't like sure so
this idea that if we just had a better
conversation i think we'd be fine no
when you're when you're dealing with
people that are
either dictatorial or
quasi-authoritarian or whatnot what they
respect is strength and that strength
has to be backed up with with the first
of all the capability to do it could you
actually make good on these promises
they all know we could
and then it's the idea of would he
actually do this
and even if they don't think he would
the bottom line is that there's a part
of him like
damn he might he might actually do it
that is the sort of stuff that can stop
a war from ever taking place in the
first place and can check aggression you
have to have the capability and the
willingness and you have to be able to
negotiate in a way that your your your
enemies don't know what you're going to
do but know that the wildest crap is
still on the table you ever play you
play poker at all a little bit not very
good sometimes so when you only with my
life when you're playing hold them
against somebody who doesn't know how to
play poker there's a certain advantage
they have in that it's hard to know what
they're doing because they're right all
over the place
so i remember when i when i first like i
was like 20 i played a game a poker
i had two seven off suit
and i went all in on it
and i got a full house oh wow and i beat
a guy who had ace king you know it was
just it was it was a good hand and he
ended up losing thinking you can't have
anything but like i got ace king and i
think he ended up with like i don't know
i don't think he had anything yeah but i
end up winning and he and he got angry
he was like why did you i'm like oh i
won didn't i oh i have lost more hands
with pocket aces than like that's right
right because you you're like it's a i
mean it's a fantastic it's one of the
best hands to go in on pre-flight
pre-flight maybe ace king suited but
anyway the point is with donald trump
putin's like i don't think he'll bomb
moscow but i also don't know if he knows
what he's doing yeah i don't know how
he'll respond
how can how can you make a plan for war
what sun tzu said
win the war before you know before you
actually start it
how could you plan against a man like
trump he was like look we're going to
wait a few years because i don't know
what this guy's doing well and he was
the the other thing too that i think
shocked a lot of people and one of the
things that impressed me most about
trump is that is how reserved he
actually was in foreign policy when it
came to actually deploying people into
harm's way to get shot at right there's
a lot of other again joe biden there's
the whole teddy roosevelt thing right
walk softly carry a big stick
joe biden mumbles and carries no stick
and and once people get used to that
idea then they know they can walk all
over you and it doesn't matter what your
capability is because you don't have the
willingness to use it
now whereas trump had the capability
again he was actually a lot more
reserved when that whole thing happened
in iran and it was no we're not going to
do this because i'm not going to
one it's a moral to kill a bunch of
people that had nothing to do with any
of this two it doesn't make sense on a
practical level to keep you know uh to
create a bunch of enemies off of killing
civilians
but when it came to syria
and then there was a legitimate thing to
strike like he struck he struck hard he
was in there quick he didn't have any
you know aspirations to like remake
syria it was just this is the weirdest
thing about the whole the whole argument
about trump and you know what he what
you know uh
why putin didn't attack
because they're acting like trump was
was favorable to russia and i guess in
some ways you can argue trump's disdain
for nato but trump's disdain for nato
there's a video going around of trump
sitting at a meeting table with them
saying why are we
paying for your defense
against russia and then you're
negotiating billion dollar gas deals
making you dependent on russia thank you
it was not helping russia that trump
sanctioned nordstrom 2.
joe biden may 2021 lifted the sanctions
on nordstream 2 and all of us were like
why are you as he was shutting down the
keystone pipeline right right and then
and then
it was appeasement is that what it was
the idea was well if we give him a
little then we can take it away if he
does bad it's like he's got nothing to
lose then yeah he's like you gave me
free stuff so i can invade anyway and
lose what i already didn't have whatever
yeah and then he did yeah putin did it
well and and he also again it's it's
this idea i i've
it's incredible to me that
there's this honest belief that
anybody's capable of sitting down at the
table and no you have completely
different objectives you have completely
different world views you you have you
know completely different capabilities
interests etc now that's not to say that
you still can't have a productive
conversation someone engage in effective
diplomacy but effective diplomacy only
takes place when people actually believe
that there will be consequences for
their actions if they go against you
and i i think
you know i wonder about vladimir putin's
frame of mind but i do know we talk a
lot about uh strass out generational
theory you're familiar with it fourth
turning hard times make strong men i
think about the motivations of vladimir
putin he wants he wants russian
greatness he wants that empire back and
he knows you know what maybe things will
get worse off for the people of russia
but that will be good for them
spiritually in the long run i'm not
saying it literally well i'm saying
that's your mentality and so his idea is
look we go to war
we are more are are more willing have
have less to lose than these western
nations and it will harden up our people
a little bit in the long run maybe he
thinks he's planting something what i
understand maybe i'm playing dev's
advocate america took iraq russia takes
ukraine china takes taiwan then we're
done with it can we just be done with it
and move on i don't i don't can we not
can we trade iraq for yeah i would love
to trade around maybe no conquest how
about that yeah greenland is going to be
super valuable in the 21st century
and beyond how about this we russia you
can have ukraine who's going to agree
with that it's denmark isn't it
the kingdom of denmark yeah talk about
getting get an ally early because in 100
years they're going to be mega powerful
unless someone sees this yeah it's going
to melt and it's going to be so much oil
and lithium and we have we have
properties
yeah we do have alaska we conquered it
didn't we no we bought it we bought it
we conquered hawaii senators yeah we
conquered hawaii yeah yeah yeah wasn't
there like like 10 years ago i think it
was a bunch of native hawaiians stormed
like the state building and occupied it
or something yeah they still get pissed
about that yeah a lot of the islanders
well yeah they're like we had a king
like america came and took it while
america wanted a pacific you know
military operation it looks like uh
putin wants the black sea he wants to
control the black sea well okay so this
this is what i think is interesting i
was talking to a buddy of mine christian
who works with us really good historian
and um he's done a lot of research on
what's going on in ukraine and we're
talking about okay what are some of the
possible angles here right because the
most obvious one is all right crimea
used to be part of russia it actually
got worked into the border with ukraine
after uh nikita khrushchev shut down the
uh the
insurgency that the ukrainians had
launched against the soviet union right
it got crimea it went from the russian
ssr over to the ukrainian ssr it was
like well that's not a big deal we're
all the ussr right well when you have
the breakaway republicans now all of a
sudden you have these areas which
ethnically culturally you could even
argue historically are more russian that
are now not part of that so okay again
if you're looking for causes bella you
could say maybe he was he's interested
in getting back parts of russia that he
thinks always belong to russia and want
to be russian anyways
but as i look at the black sea and as i
look at the the belton road initiative
by china and i look at what they're
trying to do with respect to their
overland trade
i i have a feeling that the more access
you have to the caspian sea the more
access you have to the black seed the
more important that that's going to be
from a trade and economic perspective
not to mention the fact that if he gets
away with doing this in ukraine who the
hell is going to stop him when it comes
to kazakhstan uzbekistan oh absolutely
and now we're talking about minerals
we're talking about you know overland
routes we're talking about natural gas
who's going to stop him then and look at
look at the strategy he's using donald
trump called it genius savvy and the
media has cnn actually read an article
saying trump sides with putin oh my god
did you did you trump said it was a
genius move it was savvy and it wouldn't
have happened under me it's sad
so i don't think that's siding with
putin i think he's like you know you
mentioned acknowledging that your enemy
is a genius is can be very good to
defeat your enemy that's right yeah and
so you mentioned you know in in war the
negotiating table people will only
respect power respect often people uh
people conflate some words with
positivity like greatness excitement or
respect you can respect someone and
despise them oh yeah you can be excited
and and and in despair not happy yeah
yeah yeah yeah you get citations you can
be a great man and pure evil genghis
khan great is just
magnitude
but we often view greatness in a
positive way like he was a great man
it's like that could just mean a
powerful man a conqueror right right and
there's an example and when it's funny
too you would think the same left that
whenever when when trump said make
america great again and they all came
out with their little head we'll make
america good again yeah it's like okay
so you get that there's a difference
right between the two and then when when
he comes out and says yeah this was a
genius move on his part for these
reasons it could be genius
what was he referencing when he said it
was genius specifically so vladimir
putin says oh look these regions are
independent i'm going to send in a
peacekeeping force to keep the peace and
trump was actually being sarcastic it
was like oh yeah peacekeeping force look
at all those tanks that's a peacekeeper
of course
and they're like he's siding with putin
he was he was being he was being
sarcastic yeah but it was
it was a clever move for putin to be
like well you know they're independent
so we can go help him and it's like oh
yeah so you win a war without before it
begins basically thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you